wir sprechen aber auch über die
Verantwortung wie es überhaupt zu den
explodierenden Energiepreisen kommt ohne
zu weit zurück zu gehen wenn jetzt die
Rechnung auf dem Tisch kommt ist der
Ärger bei ihnen abzuladen hat Tonka im
Finanzministerium bei ihrem Chef ein
Lindner oder müssen wir hier auf die
Konzerne gucken auf die großen
Stromkonzerne in Deutschland also ich
glaube nicht dass das was bringt wenn
man sich jetzt hier Verantwortung hin
und her schiebt wir haben die schwerste
Energiekrise seit Beginn seit bestehen
diese Republik das hat entscheidend mit
dem Krieg zu tun der in der Ukraine
geführt wird und bei dem Energie als
Waffe eingesetzt wird in Deutschland
spüren wir aber natürlich in der
Situation die erstmal von außen kommt
durch diesen Krieg dass die
Energiepolitik das letzten Jahrzehnts
mindestens das letzten Jahrzehnts nicht
klar deswegen nur ertrunken nach der
Verantwortung weil das so wahnsinnig
konkret ist man bekommt die
Stromrechnung auf dem Tisch und die
neuen Abschläge auf dem Tisch
möglicherweise sogar Stromsperren jetzt
in vielen Beispielen vor irgendein Käfer
schildert das und dann gleichzeitig gibt
es Gewinne bei den Energiekonzern bei
den Stromkonzern ist es einmal ganz
einfach gefragt in diesen Zeiten
eigentlich in Ordnung Profite Profite zu
Profite zu machen also gar nicht anders
denkbar für die Konzerne wir haben ja
erstmal nehmen wir Geld in die Hand wie
kaum ein anderes Land um die Folgen zu
mildern wir können niemandem versprechen
dass wir alle Folgen das können wir
nicht das ist in dieser Krise auch nicht
einzuhalten das versprechen wir auch
nicht aber wir bringen die Preise ja
durch die preisbremsen auf einen auf ein
Niveau von dem wir hoffen dass sie dann
auch tragfähig sind wir unterstützen
außerdem auch bedürftige Haushalte noch
direkt aber ähm zu den gewinnen da ist
ja geplant dass wir im Bereich des
stromarkts besonders hohe gewinnmarschen
die jetzt entstanden sind eben auch
abschöpfen und in die Senkung von
Strompreisen investieren das ist ja Teil
der Gesetze die diese Woche durch den
Bundestag gehen sollen weil weil wir
natürlich erkannt haben dass das auch
nötig ist und dass das auch gebraucht
wird um insgesamt die strompreisbremse
auch bezahlen als Geschäftsmann als
Energiemanager so habe ich sie
vorgestellt Chef von EnBW gewesen würden
sie in dem Moment denken als Manager
Mensch da muss ich eine sozialen
Verantwortung gerecht werden gegenüber
den Kunden da muss ich noch mal drüber
nachdenken ob die Stromerhöhung so okay
ist oder geht es tatsächlich am Ende
einfach um den Konzern gewinnen und ich
nehme was ich kriegen kann also die
heutige strompreisproblematik mal
abgesehen davon dass ich vor 15 Jahren
in
Westfalen von ihm verlassen habe die
heutige Strompreis Problematik hat ja
nicht mit nbw oder einzelnen Unternehmen
zu tun sondern mit einer jahrzehntelang
gewachsenen energiewirtschaftlichen
Struktur in der wir bestimmte
Widersprüche nicht aufgelöst haben
lassen Sie mich eins zu der
Verantwortung sagen wenn ich Frau Engel
und Käfer und Frau Balut hören dann tut
einem das weh natürlich haben wir da
alle gemeinsam eine Verantwortung und
man fragt sich vor dem Hintergrund der
Diskussion im Sport in den letzten
Wochen wer gibt uns eigentlich das Recht
uns über andere zu erheben in der Welt
wenn wir katalysieren wir nicht wissen
wie wir die eigenen Leute waren durch
den Winter bringen sollen und wenn Frau
Engel im Käfer jetzt zurecht sagt sie
macht Sorgen um die Familien die keine
Grundversorgung im Bereich Strom oder
Wärme mehr haben also wer gibt uns und
ist das nicht eigentlich auch ein
Menschenrecht und haben wir dann
eigentlich das Recht uns in der Form
über andere zu erheben die wir übrigens
trefflich noch brauchen können um
einzeln oder oder auch andere
flüssigkeitslieferanten ja wie auch
immer und es macht schon ein sehr
Merkwürdigkeit
in der Bundeswirtschaftsminister
einerseits sich dort tief verbeugt und
wir andererseits eine gesellschaftliche
Diskussion haben in der wir meinen über
andere richten zu können aber noch nicht
wissen wie wir unsere Probleme
auch völlig zurecht und wir müssen auch
über den Konzerne sprechen und meine
Frage war eben ist es in der Zeit
überhaupt in Ordnung Profite zu machen
Gewinne zu machen während andere
Stromrechnung nicht bezahlen werden
jedes Unternehmen hat auch eine
Verantwortung seinen gesellschaftlichen
Beitrag zu leisten aber die
Fiskalpolitik nicht bei Herrn Tonka und
nicht bei einem Konzern
das heißt der das heißt der Konzern muss
erstmal effizient und vernünftig
arbeiten Profit und das was davon
gegebenenfalls umverteilt wird ist
Aufgabe der fiskan und Sozialpolitik
okay und dafür haben wir ja auch das
Primat der Politik in unserem Land
übersetzen Profil völlig in Ordnung es
muss um die Gewinne gehen und am Ende
führt der Konzern ja auch Steuern ab und
das fließt dann möglicher allgemeine
möglicherweise mehr wenn das die
Politiker ein anderer Energiemanager
Ökostrom Manager Herr von sie haben
Lichtblick gegründet freuen sich
eigentlich den zufolge über jetzt
deutlich steigende Energiepreise das
Energie insgesamt wertiger teurer wird
das glaube ich ist ganz wichtig in der
Tat ja dass wir
endlich
spüren was wirklich Energie für einen
Wert hat und wir dadurch auch angehalten
werden Energie zu sparen und in
Effizienzmaßnahmen zu zu investieren
aber das darf natürlich nicht dahin
gehen dass die Energiepreise steigen
weil über die Maßen Gewinne
erwirtschaftet werden da würde ich gerne
noch mal einhaken und Wortteil im
Klassen sagen Gewinne sind vollkommen in
Ordnung freie Marktwirtschaft braucht
Unternehmen mit Gewinnen das geht gar
nicht anders aber was die Politik
natürlich jetzt leisten muss ist das zum
einen die sogenannten übergewinne
abgeschöpft werden ja das also das was
auch gesetzlich regulatorisch völlig
falsch gelaufen ist dass die Produzenten
von erneuerbaren Energien jahrzehntelang
gefördert wurden weil ihre Energie zu
teuer war und sie heute bei den hohen
Energiepreisen wahnsinnig viel Geld
verdienen und das alles behalten dürfen
ja damit wurden wurden die Verluste
sozialisiert und sie sind und das dürfen
wir noch mal auf den Kunden runter weil
dazu habe ich dieses Beispiel hier etwas
südlich von Berlin ist eine
Stromrechnung die jetzt gerade
reingekommen ist die ist gut drei Wochen
alt und da ist der neue Abschlag
gekennzeichnet können einmal drauf
gucken hier auf diese Rechnung hier
steht der neue arbeitsspreis 71 Cent
bisher waren das steht da ganz klein
drunter in dem ansonsten sehr
freundlichen Anschreiben 35 59 das also
der Arbeitspreis der sich mal locker
dort verdoppelt hat das ganze ein
Ökostrom Anbieter derjenige dem diese
Rechnung zugestellt worden ist
der fragt sich der hat sich bewusst für
Ökostrom entschieden warum eigentlich
Wind und Strom ist nicht teurer geworden
in der Zeit die Stromerzeugung ist bei
meinem Ökostromanbieter nicht teurer
geworden ich zahl das Doppelte erklären
das kann man erklären das Licht einfach
daran dass auch die Erzeuger von
windkraft und Solarenergie ihren Strom
im Markt an der Börse verkaufen und
damit den Marktpreis für Ihre Ware
erhalten ja dadurch
seine bewussten Entscheidung für Öko
Ökostrom zahlte im Moment die teuren
Kohlekraftwerke und vor allen Dingen
Gaskraftwerke mit das ist genau der
Punkt den ich eben mit den übergewinnen
meinte ja das darf nicht sein dass die
Erzeuger diese
regenerativen Energien jetzt so
wahnsinnig viel Gewinne machen als als
windfallprovence nur weil der der Preis
einer Börse nach oben gegangen ist aber
hier muss genau bei dieser Stromrechnung
die Sie gerade gezeigt haben muss doch
die Politik jetzt reingehen und sagen
wir müssen nicht eine allgemeine
strompreisbremse machen ja von der wie
alle die wir sitzen profitieren ja das
ist natürlich totaler Nonsens sondern
wir müssen den Leuten helfen die
wirklich Probleme kriegen die sich also
ganz konkret zu der Rechnung das ist ja
ein Witz in weiten ganz schlechter Witz
der Strom ist kein Stück teurer geworden
der zahlt aber das Doppelte in Zukunft
an Arbeitspreis
gasbremse hilft erstmal im Dezember das
stimmt auch in den Erfolge Monaten oder
nee äh Übernahme der Abschläge dann die
gaspreisbremse aber danach zahlt da eben
dann den verdoppelten Arbeit ab Januar
im Endeffekt 40 Cent also das Ding
dieses Problem ist das ist natürlich
erstmal eine ganz extrem hohe
Arbeitsweise und hat momentan etwas 45
Cent als Neukunde
oder so der tagesaktuelle Neukundenpreis
aber ganz egal wie der Vertrag aussieht
es wird ab Januar dann im Endergebnis 40
Cent sein für Privatverbraucher was
derzeit auch der auch der Kunde ganz
genau wegen der Strompreis Bremse und
trotzdem müssen wir uns einmal den
Anbieter angucken warum ist das so die
zocken ab in dem Fall der
Ökostromanbieter der produziert
mittlerweile günstig und locker die
Kosten ein die er eigentlich für die
Produktion in dem Gaskraftwerken und
Kohlekraftwerk bekäme ich will ich will
das nicht beurteilen wenn es
Ökostromanbieter gibt die günstiger sind
dann wäre der Wechsel natürlich zu
empfehlen ganz klar das Problem was wir
im Strommarkt haben ist aber nicht so
einfach zu lösen das ist ja im Grunde
dass der Gaspreis und der Strompreis
quasi verheiratet sind ist der Gaspreis
sehr hoch und der hat sich etwas
vervielfacht in eineinhalb Jahren dann
schlägt das auch auf den Strompreis eben
durch weil eben Gaskraftwerke auch zur
Stromerzeugung eingesetzt werden und
dann auch in die Preisberechnung
einfließen und da kommen die sehr sehr
hohen Gewinner her die zum Teil bei Wind
oder Solar entstehen oder auch bei
konventionellen Kraftwerken die wir
allerdings sehr teilweise dann auch
nutzen um den Strompreis an anderer
Stelle zu senken
das Thema dabei dass man irgendwie sagt
ja kann man jetzt machen nichts bzw der
Tonka sagt für die Regierung übernehmen
wir halten Teil natürlich jetzt
staatlich ne ab Dezember und dann mit
der strompreisbremse kann ja auch nicht
die Lösung sein Ökostrom Anbieter
verdoppelt man lässig
ich meine Aufgabe diesen Ökostrom
Anbieter hier im Einzelnen zu
kritisieren dass es nämlich zwei Dinge
generell sagen die wenn bestimmte
Unternehmen preislich die aktuelle
Situation ausnutzen ist das schlecht
aber das Grundproblem ist nicht von
Unternehmen im Moment gemacht sondern
dadurch dass wir seit Jahrzehnten und
auch zu Zeiten der Energiewende eine
konsequente in sich inkonsistente
Energiepolitik betreiben in der wir im
Grunde gar nicht mehr wissen was wir
wollen in der wir sagen Kernenergie
wollen wir nicht Steinkohle wollen wir
auch nicht braun Kohle wollen wir auch
nicht dann wollten wir temporär
russisches Gas haben uns völlig
einseitig darauf verlegt und haben jetzt
eine Situation wo wir grundsätzlich
sehen wie gefährlich das ist wenn man
sich in einer einseitige Abhängigkeit
begibt und im Grunde hat die Politik
noch das Glück dass sie Putin
vorschieben kann als den vermeintlich
Schuldigen denn durch die putin
immeratik ist jetzt überhaupt ein
Problem virulent geworden was ist
zugrunde liegend sich über 10 20
wunderbare entwickelt vertiefen wir
gleich genau diese Frage Herr Klassen
letztes Mal zu dem Beispiel ich fand es
eben so irre weil eben es eine Rechnung
ist die sich auf Wind und Strom bezieht
auf öko-Energie wo kommt eigentlich im
Moment dieser Ökostrom wir müssen jetzt
gar nicht den speziellen Anbieter nehmen
wo kommt eigentlich im Moment der
Ökostrom her wir haben seit Wochen nicht
besonders viel Wind in Deutschland und
wir haben seit Wochen zumindest hier in
Berlin Null Sonne ja unabhängig davon
woher kommt sage ich gleich noch was zu
noch einen Satz zu diesem Preis den sie
eben genannt haben ja der
Ökostromanbieter kriegt den Ökostrom
auch auf dem Markt gar nicht billiger ja
also insofern von Abzocke zu sprechen
ist nicht korrekt an dieser Stelle
sondern die Gesetze die die der
regulatorische Rahmen ist so gestrickt
im Moment von der Politik das die
Kilowattstunde Strom ganz egal ob sie
immer Atomkraftwerk erzeugt wurde im
Kohlekraftwerk oder in der
Windkraftanlage gleich viel an der Börse
kostet ja also dieser ökostromhändler
der oft Ökostrom ein und hat gar nicht
die Möglichkeit den Strom billiger zu
und kauft er im Moment überhaupt das war
ja meine Frage Ökostrom ein oder gehst
ja Ökostrom hier bei dem Anbieter und
bei anderen im Moment gar kein ökostein
also davon keine Ahnung ich kenne den
Anbieter nicht aber davon gehe ich nicht
aus die sind ja auch alle zertifiziert
ich glaube schon dass die Ökostrom
Einkaufen das Problem ist dass das
Unternehmen
gebucht habe kriege ich dann in diesen
dunklen Tagen in den Tagen ohne Wind
kriege ich garantiert jeden Tag ja
selbstverständlich nein natürlich ich
glaube dass das bei allen
Ökostromanbietern so ist das Problem
sind gar nicht die Händler sondern das
Problem sind die Erzeuger der
Kilowattstunden ja also die Besitzer der
Solar und Windkraftanlagen die in den
letzten 15 Jahren vom EEG profitiert
haben also eine Förderung bekommen haben
weil sie selber teurer produziert haben
als der Markt ihn vergütet hat und jetzt
hat sich das alles umgedreht ja jetzt
plötzlich sind sie wettbewerbsfähig sind
die günstigste Art Strom zu erzeugen
tatsächlich der Fall ist in Deutschland
die günstigste Art Strom
und die verdienen jetzt wahnsinnig viel
Geld weil das Gesetz eben nicht diesen
Fall berücksichtigt hat damals weil man
überhaupt nie davon ausgegangen ist dass
der Preis mal so in solchen verdienen
wahnsinniges Geld und in dem Fall dieser
Kunde muss wahnsinnig viel Geld
plötzlich draufzahlen was konkret kann
ich machen wenn ich so ein Schreiben
jetzt auf dem Tisch bekomme wie wäre ich
mich kann ich mich wehren überhaupt ich
möchte auch noch mal prinzipiell was
sagen wir stellen das tatsächlich in der
letzten Zeit fest als diese preist diese
Bremse in in so und die Medien gekommen
ist dass die kommen wird
also ich persönlich habe das auch erlebt
ich habe im Anfang November meine
Jahresendabrechnung bekommen auch von
dem Ökostrom Anbieter und da wurde mir
auch gesagt wir können den Preis
konstant halten und die eg-umlage ist ja
auch gefallen klasse jetzt kommen wir
mal richtig zur Geltung und zum ersten
12 kam dann die Erhöhung über knapp über
ist tatsächlich unsere
Vermutung dass da sehr viel
Intransparenz dabei ist
fühlen sie sich da ausgenutzt weil wir
berichten heute hier bei Bild auch über
noch ganz andere Beispiele wattenfall
macht Lockangebote zahlt Prämien um in
die Tarife zu locken und dann knallt am
Ende ein hoher Arbeitspreis rein weil
der Kunde das ja meistens gar nicht
zahlen muss 80 % Federn sie ab und der
das kommt alles vom Staat das heißt Sie
zahlen am Ende die die
Strompreiserhöhung und gar nicht so sehr
erkunde können sich abgezockt nein ich
will mich nicht abgezockt aber es ist
ganz sicher so dass wir sehr genau im
Gasmarkt und dem Strom Markt uns ansehen
müssen die verhalten sich die Preise in
Deutschland auch im Vergleich zu anderen
Ländern und wenn es da Auffälligkeiten
gibt dann wird er auch eingeschnitten
werden
Vermutung gewesen ich würde die auch
tatsächlich ernst nehmen also ich will
die nicht aber es ist auch es ist auch
bleiben
Bremse besteht diese diese Preis Bremsen
sind ja so gemacht dass das nur ein
grundkontingent günstiger zu haben ist
und wer gleich viel Strom verbraucht wie
im Vorjahr der Zahl für die letzten 20
Prozent auch den Marktpreis also es ist
ja schon so dass es für den Kunden nicht
egal ist was der Strom kostet oder was
für ein Tarif hat und das ist auch
absichtlich so gemacht worden um genau
diesen Missbrauch möglich
wenn sie so eine Regelung bekommen vom
Staat dann reiben Sie sich doch ja in
vergangenen Zeiten bei EnBW vor 15
Jahren die Hände und sagen na wunderbar
es schade den Kunden nicht höchstens den
Steuerzahlern am Ende dem Kunden aber
erstmal nicht der merkt das gar nicht
ich hole mir das Geld aus dem
Finanzminister
war aber unsere Hauptaufgabe intern
effizienter zu werden und unsere
Hausaufgaben zu machen und nicht
irgendwelche
erlaubten oder missbräuchlichen
preisgestaltungspotenzial auszunutzen
ich würde auch bei der Mehrzahl der
Unternehmen das nicht unterstellen zu
Vattenfall kann ich nichts sagen war
mein Wettbewerber ich bin ganz sicher
nicht wattenfall aber es ist ja egal wir
reden ja über die Ziele gar nicht aber
insofern ist wahrscheinlich dass der der
Schlüssel zur Lösung
Mechanismen finden die jetzt die Not
lindern in einer Form die für die
Unternehmen und auch für Spekulanten
möglichst wenig Missbrauchspotential
schaffen möglichst viel direkt Hilfe und
keine Bürokratiemonster weil am
Bürokratie Monster leidet am Ende der
Staat und der Bürger immer am meisten
und die kniffligen Trickser profitieren
jetzt noch einmal zu der Frage und
gleich auf ein Käfer verballert jetzt
liegt er ja die die Rechnung auf dem
Tisch die neue Abschlagszahlung was
mache ich erstens mal gucke ich ist das
überhaupt möglich dass er den Preis
erhöht habe ich noch ein Festpreis der
hat zwei Jahre ging und ich bin noch ein
Jahr dabei
ist die ist das preiserhöhungsschreiben
ordentlich also ne ist das
wie soll ich das jetzt sagen genügt das
den rechtlichen Vorgaben okay das ist
verdammt schwer zu prüfen ja dafür sind
wir ja da das ist ja unsere Verbraucher
wenn das alles so rechtens ist dann
müsste ich also erstens mal würde ich
mich dann sofort beschweren beim
Kartellamt ne weil das steht halt immer
im Verdacht so ein bisschen auf 71 Cent
Arbeitspreis das ist schon echt tot auch
da hilft die Verbraucherzentrale weil
der sitzt sie zu Hause im kleinen
Häuschen und denkt ja wie beschwere ich
mich beim karteller die haben wunderbare
Internetauftritt mit mit Musterbrief mit
allen möglichen mit allen
Ansprechpartnern und allen Kram ne also
da findet man alles mögliche wir helfen
in der persönlichen Beratung allerdings
sind wir da auch ein bisschen
überfordert und wir freuen uns dann
schon auf nächstes Jahr wenn dann die
Abrechnung mit diesen Bremsen kommen
weil dann wird es ganz lustig ähm und
der der dritte Möglichkeit ist natürlich
und die vierte also einsparen das ist
mein Spezialisten machen die
allermeisten sowieso schon verstand das
machen sie nicht und das vierte wäre
dann tatsächlich eventuell zu einem
anderen Versorger zu gehen aber da
finden sie momentan nur den
Grundversorger sie sagen die Deutschen
sparen noch nicht
wie viel Kilowattstunden verbrauchen sie
im Jahr ich weiß es nicht aber ich weiß
was im Moment alles nicht läuft bei uns
und wo überall das Licht aus ist wo es
vorher anders war die Leute wie viel
Kilowattstunden sie verbrauchen weil das
ist nämlich das allererste um richtig zu
sparen dass man erstmal weiß was
verbrauche ich überhaupt vorher kann man
überhaupt nicht anfangen mit sparen
wollen Clips bei den Lichtschalter aus
und vergisst das Aquarium was da
irgendwie 2000k ein Eindruck ist das
schon sehr sehr viel gespart wird
aktuell in Deutschland Käfer haben sie
haben sie eine Grenze wo sie sagen
würden ab da ist eine
Strompreiserhöhung Energiepreis für
Erhöhung unverschämt also ich glaube
dass das in vielen Fällen der Fall ist
und ich würde für allererst mal sagen
hier ist die Politik gefordert auch die
Kartell Behörde stärker einzuschalten
wir als Verbraucher haben können das
überhaupt nicht ich nehme die
Abschlagszahlung geht zur
Verbraucherzentrale lass mich da
informieren und die Verbraucherzentrale
muss ich selber erstmal ans Kartellamt
bin aber wo ist so eine Grenze für sie
erreicht ja das kann nicht sein das kann
wo ich meinen Lebensunterhalt nicht mehr
bestreiten kann ich habe ihn ja eben das
Beispiel erzählt von der
alleinerziehende Mutter mit dem Kindern
die tagelang ihren Strom abgesperrt
hatte weil sie weil sie nicht mehr
zahlen konnte und ich weiß es gibt
verschiedene Anregungen was man alles
tun kann wie man auf dem Versorger
zugehen kann wie man Ratenzahlungen
vereinbaren kann aber die Menschen die
nichts in der Tasche haben die können
auch keine Ratenzahlungen machen die
sind drauf angewiesen dass sie irgendwie
Hilfe bekommen und die können auch nicht
selber zum Kartellamt gehen und
nachzuweisen dass das eine Abzocker ist
deshalb ja auch an unsere Anforderungen
an die Politik auch als Sozialverband
diese übergewinne abzuschöpfen und da
sind sie in der Pflicht auch hier die
entsprechende Expertise an den Tag zu
legen das können wir überhaupt nicht das
kann auch kein private Haushalt das kann
kein allein erzählen
ich weiß nur dass eine FDP-Mann
Wirtschaftsminister ist der nein das ist
ein grüner Finanzminister ist ein grüner
es Wirtschaftsminister und beide müssen
sich zusammentun und müssen
entsprechende Voraussetzungen schaffen
vielleicht unglücklich gewählt weil es
geht ja um missbräuchliche Gewinne oder
um Spekulationsgewinne die aus einer
ganz spezifischen Notsituation
resultieren herauskommen und ich glaube
wenn man es umdefinieren würde kann man
es für alle einschließlich für die
Unternehmen
verständlicher und akzeptabler machen
denn niemand versteht das Gut
erwirtschaftete Gewinne schlecht sind
aber jeder versteht das missbraucht
nicht oder trickreich erwirtschaftete
Gewinne stärker bescheuert werden